[Music]
foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday November 23rd I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal
every year the Wall Street journal's
personal Tech Team tests out a range of
gadgets and gear and puts together a
list of their top picks for holiday
gifts but this year with the prices of
everything creeping up and layoffs being
announced left and right particularly in
the tech sector the team focused on
items that are sure to be worth their
money nothing that's destined for a spot
at the back of the closet covered in
dust
joining us to share their list is
personal Tech columnist Nicole Nguyen
personal Tech reporter Dalvin Brown and
personal Tech reporting assistant
Cordelia James
thank you all so much for coming on the
show hello hey thanks again all right
let's jump into this list I noticed
there were quite a lot of Fitness
related gifts on there Cordelia can you
tell us about one of them
yeah so one of the gifts that I
recommended was the dribble up smart
boxing gloves so it's super it's just
like a fun way to spice up your workout
from home routine So I myself am like a
boxing Noob I don't know too much about
just the best way to box and so this was
like an easy setup really just like a
good way to track your reps and there
are just so many different sessions that
you can follow both on demand and live
and if you ultimately don't want to
spend the 17 bucks a month for the
membership there are still a couple of
practice sessions available and at the
end of the day you still have a nice set
of gloves to use okay well you know in
that same vein there seem to be a number
of wearables on this list what did you
stick on and why Nicole so one of the
wearables that I chose on this list is
the Garmin epics it's a pretty chunky
watch like most garments are but it has
a touch screen and so it's the most
Smart Watch like wearable that I think
garmin's put out they typically have a
five button interface that requires DDR
Dance Dance Revolution style
choreography just to perform simple
tasks but the touchscreen makes it
really really easy and for people who
are interested in the outdoors or their
long distance athletes I think this
would be an amazing thing to open up on
Christmas day and I also chose the
Fitbit sense to wearable Fitbit hasn't
really come out with a smart watch in a
number of years the sense 2 was really
interesting though because it comes with
a stress sensor that can detect physical
indications of stress so when you're
stressed out the thing that you need is
your wrist to buzz and tell you that
you're stressed out and it'll nudge you
to take a little meditation or some
breathing exercises or a moment to relax
I think we can all probably use a nice
reminder to take a deep breath you know
over the last couple years we've
definitely been talking about more gifts
for the home since we've obviously been
spending a lot more time in our houses
Delvin are there any good gifts for the
home this year
yeah so one of the good gifts for home
that I recommended this year was the
echo dot with clock so it's another
Alexa enabled smart speaker but what
makes it really interesting is that you
can use it to extend your Wi-Fi network
and it's also useful because it has a
little digital screen that shows
temperature or song titles so if you
don't want to call out for Alexa as
often you don't have to because a little
screen will show it to you you know
Nicole this was more of a practical list
this year so what's a good practical
gift that you stuck on one of my picks
for this guide is a laptop sleeve by
moft which looks like a very boring
laptop sleeve from the outside but when
you take your laptop out and you fold
along these little folded lines it pops
up in this origami-esque way to become a
stand so for anyone who works from
coffee shops or is on the road a lot
this is the perfect thing I use it all
the time there are two height options
even a lower one for typing and then a
higher ones that you can get more
flattering angle when you're video
calling or just browsing the web what
about something fun Dalvin do we have
anything fun on the list
yeah so one of the fun items I
recommended this year is like a tick
tock Era music mixer and if you are a
content creator or a kid that likes to
make a lot of noise Ruckus FX is a great
great option and it's only 50 bucks I
have it right here
imagine downloading your favorite song
onto a little handheld device and then
like doing your favorite Tick Tock dance
but like each movement remixes the song
in a different way so like if this is
the song and you're like punching and
twisting
I'm not a tick tock dancer yeah it looks
like it's got this little handle it
looks almost like I don't know like a
bop it I'm trying to think of it too
um but like I think the idea is like you
can create really cool content dancing
to it in like you know a dark room and
just create something really visually
appealing and upload your remix track to
tick tock you know I think maybe if
we're looking for something that's a
little less ruckussy and a little more
hanging out and chilling I noticed that
there was this Samsung freestyle
projector it's 800 so it's more on the
expensive side of this year's list why
did you include it Delvin yeah so there
are a few things that make it somewhat
essential and certainly unique so the
projector has all the apps that you're
you may be used to seeing on a Samsung
Smart TV it comes with Netflix and all
that baked in but one of the things
that's really unique about it is you can
power it using a light socket so you
literally screw the projector in where
you would screw in a light bulb and you
can project mood lighting into a room or
you know if you put it above the dining
room table maybe it's a personalized
table setting for the holidays so you
know it does a lot more than just
project high quality images onto a white
screen it's pretty fun let's keep going
with this splurging trend if you want to
spend a little bit more for this holiday
season Cordelia anything you'd recommend
I'd recommend the valve steam deck it's
like this handheld gaming device for
those who love playing PC games the
graphics are absolutely amazing it's a
little bit bigger than something like a
Nintendo switch for example if someone
is a really big gamer in your family I
would suggest probably getting one of
the devices that have a lot more space
you can get one either 64 gigabytes 256
gigabytes or 512 that 5-12 one is about
a little over 600 like around 650
dollars but something else that you
should know is the games that take up
the most space and probably are like the
most detailed also drain the battery so
you might want to keep a backup battery
pack handy too I mean I think all Tech
gifts we should always think about the
batteries an important lesson for
everybody when they give Tech well
that's our personal Tech Team joining us
with this year's wsj tech gift guide
Cordelia James Nicole Nguyen Dalvin
Brown thank you guys so much for joining
us thank you thank you thanks for having
us
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing heads up we'll be off tomorrow
for Thanksgiving but we'll be back with
more Tech news for you on Friday and in
the meantime you can find more Tech
stories on our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]